if you had the opportunity to go and
view any culture from the past like if
you could be completely invisible and
walk around amongst the Romans or cave
people or Native Americans before the
Europeans came what would you choose
wow that's really hard question yeah the
first time where anything was trying to
be colonized
it changed like the first time I got
Botox up Mike that some white people got
out right we're used to being in the
fields every day and this guy hunts and
this guy watches after the boys and
teaches them and and then all of a
sudden they come out and they're built
like you guys need to live the women are
staring at their [ __ ] balls two feet
from the ground what are these things
are they what the [ __ ] is going in his
[ __ ] ear can I get a Bible can you
[ __ ] it round them up call Tommy the
boys we're gonna need about 40 these
[ __ ] things climb trees what is your
character's name I love this guy he
needs to come back more often this is
the kind as a tree yes Joe they climb
trees